Jean-Luc dyin responsable Croix-Rouge on
va maintenant voir avec vous comment se
passe la préparation de la future halte
détente Alzheimer du côté de
morpa Jean-Luc Guilin donc responsable
de la croix- rouge à Saint-Quentin en
Eveline expliquez-nous comment va se
présenter cette halte détente Alzheimer
à qui elle va s'adresser au malades pour
que les familles soient soulagées c'est
ça dans les grand voilà c'est c'est tout
à fait ça en fait on s'aperçoit que il y
a plus d'un million de de malades de la
maladie d'Alzheimer en France il y a
environ 250000 cas nouveaux qui sont
déclarés chaque année ça veut dire que
ça concerne plus de 3 millions de
personnes parce que l'entourage en fait
deux malades sur trois V chez à domicile
et donc pris en charge par la
famille c'est une prise en charge qui
est relativement lourde quand c'est 24
he sur 24 et 7 jours sur 7 donc l'idée
c'est de aider autant que faire ce peu
ses aidans à prendre un peu de répis
parce que c'est répis détente pour les
aidans de manière à ce que pendant
quelques heures ben une équipe de
bénévoles formé spécifiquement à à cette
action prennent en charge le malade le
resocialise un tout petit peu pendant
quelques heures a pend quelques heures
voilà un samedi après-midi dans un
premier temps et puis mais pour
l'instant ce sera ouvert l'ouverture est
programmée seulement pour le samedi hein
ou dans un premier temps on ouvre ben on
va y aller doucement c'est quand même
une action relativement grave
relativement
sérieuse il faut pas qu'on se trompe
donc on préfère y aller doucement
attendre que tout le monde soit bien
formé là actuellement vous faites la
formation l'ouverture je le reprécise ce
sera du côté de de morpa bien sûr on
donnera l'adresse les renseignements qui
vont s'afficher à l'antenne l'ouverture
sera du côté de morpa il y aura un
bénévole pour un malade accueilli c'est
l'idée c'est au moins un bénévole pour
un malade accueilli peut-être un
responsable de de équipe et vous formez
actuellement ces bénévoles on est en
train de former ces bénévoles voilà
combien de bénévoles vont être formés
parce que ça va dépendre quaine une
quinzaine donc à peu près une quinzaine
de personnes atteintent de la maladie
pouront être accueill non non non non on
accueillera entre 4 C malades par le
samedi et comment ça va se dérouler
justement il va y avoir une liste
comment on s'incrit on na pas tout à
fait tout à fait terminé hein on est on
est en train de faire la mise au point
oui il y aura une inscription parce
qu'on aura besoin d'un certificat
médical nous ne prenons les malade que à
un certain degré encore de de dépendance
voilà au début de maladie parce qu'après
ça demande un suivi médical une prise de
médicaments par exemple que nous ne
ferons pas c'est
pas c'est pas une structure médicalisée
c'est géré par des bénévoles donc bon
même si dans le lot des bénévoles qui
sont qui se sont fait connaître et qui
participent à la formation nous avons
des des professionnels de santé on a la
chance d'avoir la verrière à côté donc
on a quelques personnes de la verriè qui
vont venir nous aider mais c'est pas
c'est pas dans le casre de leur métier
donc c'est dans tous les cas dans le cas
de bénévola donc nous nous me tenons pas
à prendre des malades dans un état trop
avancé ou ou qui sont parfois un peu
vindicatifs ou autres on pourra pas on
n'ura pas la structure pour difficile
donc pour les bénévoles de les encadrer
l'ouverture au mieux minovembre
minovembre voilà voir début janvier
éventuellement le temps que vraiment
tout soit prêt on nous l'avit dit prê
bien préparé voilà voà je encore
rencontrer le le le maire de morp pour
mettre au point un certain nombre de
détails nous avons les salles sont
réservées le la salle c'est la maison
des Coudrais donc c'est à cheval entre
morpa et lancour donc ça sera facile
pour les familles de de morpas ou des
lancour de venir mais ce sera ouvert aux
familles d'un peu plus loin de 50
an tous les alentours bon on prendra les
inscriptions et puis on verra comment ça
se passe et et quel coût combien ça va
coûter aux familles alors on sait pas
encore on hésite entre rien et 5 € donc
ça sera pas cher dans tous les cas
merci d'être venu sur le plateau nous
parler de cette halte je vais vous
garder encore quelques instants avec
nous puisqueon va parler de l'autre
actualité hein les actions que vous
menez envers les les jeunes 12 25 ans on
va en parler ce sera juste après ce
reportage sur l'épicerie d'élancours de
la Croix-Rouge dont l'activité est très
chargée en ce moment sur les étagères
les produits de première nécessité sont
pris d'assaut et les rayons dévalisés
l'épicerie sociale de la Croix-Rouge
d'élencour créée en 2011 tente de faire
face à l'afflux massif récent de
demandeurs d'asile près de 70 familles
adressées par les centres communaux
d'action sociale une population qui
s'ajoute aux habitués des familles des
personnes seules hein il y a beaucoup de
personnes au chômage des personnes des
retraitées de plus en plus hein faut pas
oublier les personnes en retraite
connaissent aussi de beaucoup de
difficultés pour payer leur charge leur
loyer en juillet dernier l'épicerie
sociale se munit d'une chambre froide
indispensable pour l'apport en fruits et
légumes frais de plus en plus il y a
beaucoup de monde bah qui sont dans les
secours populaires
comme tout ce qui est alimentation quoi
donc c'est je vois que les gens c'est de
plus en plus difficile pour tout le
monde quoi un sentiment partagé par les
bénévoles du relais d'lancour qui estime
toutefois que le nombre de bénéficiaires
inscrits n'est pas le reflet de la
réalité je pense qu'il y en a quand même
beaucoup qui ne viennent pas encore qui
n'osent pas venir parce que c'est c'est
pas évident du tout hein pour de faire
la démarche d'aller voir un travailleur
social et et de faire la démarche de
venir ici c'est c'est une difficulté
qu'il faut surmonter
en 2012 305 nouvelles familles ont
franchi les portes de l'épicerie sociale
la situation est très tendue sur cette
épicerie sur é encour oui bon ça va se
calmer un peu en fait parce qu'on s'est
aperçu qu'un certain nombre de familles
de réfugiés étaient reparti depuis mais
comme les informations ne sont pas
envoyées par le SEM social il faut qu'on
les trouve nous-même et on les a raté un
petit peu pendant quelques temps et là
on est en train de faire un peu de
nettoyage parce qu'on s'est aperçu qu'on
était en train de nourrir la région
parisienne en son sens son ensemble donc
de à partir d'aujourd'hui on a commencé
à mettre un peu d'ordre parce qu'on on a
pu avoir finalement la confirmation des
gens qui sont vraiment présents et qui
sont pas vraiment présents il y a eu un
peu de de turnover donc est-ce que vous
êtes inquiet pour l'hiver qui s'annonce
on sait pour les restos ce sera
difficile pour la Croix-Rouge sera
également cas ça va être on est inquiet
parce qu'on sait pas ce que l'Europe va
faire donc une partie des aliments que
nous avons viennent de de la dotation
européenne donc on sait pas si ça va
continuer même si il y a eu un surc ça a
été maintenu encore pendant quelques
temps oui oui mais c'est la dernière
année donc on sait pas très bien ce que
ça va donner à partir de maintenant
euh B la crise malheureusement se
ressent à tous les niveaux quand on
entend le nombre de chômeurs et tout ça
on peut penser que malheureusement on va
avoir de plus en plus de demandes euh
bah on on fera face on va on va trouver
les solutions pour faire face la Croix
Rouge qui est donc présent sur tous les
fronts vous développez des actions
verers les jeunes aussi les 12 25 ans
voilà oui c'est ça euh bon c'est une
volonté de la Croix-Rouge que d'essayer
de d'attirer de de jeunes bénévoles donc
nous avons mis en place une équipe
jeunesse ça se fait dans un certain
nombre de délégations Croix-Rouge en
France
euh c'est ce sont des jeunes qui vont
avoir qui vont participer aux actions
classiques c'est qu'il viendront aider
dans les épiceries sociales dans la
vesti boutique ou autres mais qui auront
des actions spécifiques comme par
exemple des visites de maison de
retraite ou autres c'est eux-mêmes qui
vont décider ce qu'ils font donc on a
mis ça en place depuis quelques mois on
a actuellement une quinzaine de
bénévoles et une dizaine de demandes de
de de de candidats bénévol si je peux
appeler
le sont des jeunes qui sont motivés
voilà donc le le 10 novembre il y a la
red touch day voilà pour le dire comme
ça doit être dit donc c'est un jour
c'est la Journée européenne des langues
étrangères on en parlait en début
d'émission voilà on en parlait tout à
l'heure voilà voilà et donc les les les
jeunes de l'équipe de Saint-Quentin
feront une action spécifique sur
Saint-Quentin et il est encore possible
de vous contacter si les
jeunesel DEES
toujours à la recherche bien évidemment
de
bénév refuse pas les bonnes volonté
merci d'être venu sur ce plateau on
reprécise que la halte destente
Alzheimer dont nous parlions il y a
quelques instants avec vous ouvririt
mi-novembre voire début janvier sur les
les dates que vous nous avez communiqué
tout à l'heure on aura l'occasion de
d'être un peu plus précis au cours des
prochaines semaines le 78 est presque
fini pour ce soir on revient ensemble
sur les principaux titres une première
en France un partenariat public privé
afin de réaliser une résidence pour
personnes âgées cela se déroule à
Versailles l'établissement sera finalisé
en 2016 depuis cet été l'épicerie
sociale d'élancour gérée par la
Croix-Rouge elle s'est doté d'une
chambre froide pour fournir des drées
fraîches aux bénéficiaires des
bénéficiaires vous l'avez entendu il y a
quelques instants de plus en plus
nombreux en ce ce mois de septembre
c'était aujourd'hui la Journée
européenne des langues l'université de
Versailles Saint-Quentin a organisé une
journée de rencontre le directeur du
Centre des langues était avec nous il y
a moins d'une demi-heure son interview
est à retrouver dès demain matin jeudi
sur notre site Internet et puis il n'y a
pas du vin uniquement dans les régions
viticol à H encour l'association des
Amis du passé vendange tous les ans et
cette année la récolte permettra de
réaliser 120 l de vin c'est la fin de
cette édition du 26 septembre demain
vous retrouverez Catherine zulato DS 18h
en direct avec de nouveaux invités pour
faire un point complet sur l'actualité
locale excellente
soirée